je vous le disais dans les titres suite
aux précipitations des derniers jours la
hausse des niveaux d'eau déjà élevé se
poursuit la vienne tourangelle est en
vigilance jaune aujourd'hui encore selon
le site vigicrues
depuis deux jours à chinon le niveau de
la rivière a dépassé celui de la
dernière crue de 2016
quelques habitants ont même déjà les
pieds dans l'eau notamment sur l'île de
tours florent clavel a donc dû chausser
ses bottes pour aller à leur rencontre
regardez depuis les hauteurs de chinon
de l'eau à perte de vue
on ne distingue plus le lit de la vienne
la rivière est en crue plus bas les
premières routes coupées et des
habitants les pieds dans l'eau
c'est le cas notamment sur l'île de
tours situées au milieu du cours d'eau
roger 74 ans nous ouvre sa porte
bienvenue à la maison un peu humide en
ce moment nous avons tous surélevé à
c'est toujours un petit peu plus
compliqué que d'habitude puisqu'il faut
prendre les bottes pour sortir
philosophe roger
il faut dire qu'il est habitué 15 cru en
18 ans soit quasiment une chaque année
sa maison en porte d'ailleurs les
stigmates grâce à vigicrues le site de
prévision des inondations
il a pu anticiper donc on voit la courbe
le retraité a surélevé ses meubles et
s'est préparé à vivre essentiellement à
laitages tout en continuant à garder un
oeil avisé sur le niveau de l'eau la
vienne vous voyez ici le niveau de la
vienne puisque par capillarité est là
elle arrive à son niveau où elle est
actuellement dans son lit là est donc
ici donc une cuisine une cuisine d'été
paix voilà vous avez appris à vivre avec
moi et complètement
le niveau de la rivière atteint
actuellement les quatre mètres 90 en
indre et loire
elle est la seule lettre en vigilance
jaune c'est à dire avec un risque plus
important de débordements en prévision
la ville a fait évacuer le bétail dans
les plaines inondables isolé des routes
et fermer le réseau d'eaux pluviales
pour éviter que l'oni nom de centre
ville
enfin en cas de coup dur on se prépare à
mettre en place dans certaines zones un
peu sensible de la ville des moyennes
pompage ou quand il y en aurait besoin
et au cas où en particulier la météo
viendrait avec des fortes pluies nous
perturber donc on se prépare en
particulier pour passer ce week-end mais
on est on à une relative sérénité parce
que c'est des situations qu'on a déjà
connu dans le passé
une sérénité justifier également par
l'évolution du niveau de la vienne selon
vigicrues ils devraient stagner voire
commencer à baisser légèrement